nächste rednerin jetzt katrin göring
eckardt vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen kolleginnen kollegen frau
bundeskanzlerin ja es ist gut fehler
zuzugeben und das hilft der demokratie
weiter es ist aber natürlich auch
zwingend aus fehlern zu lernen
es gibt ideen es gibt konzepte
es gibt erfindungen dieses schwere lage
zu bestehen was aber dieser
bundesregierung fehlt ist pragmatismus
in schuss kraft und mut daraus wirklich
etwas zu machen über die appelle an die
menschen hinaus meine damen und herren
es holten sich es häufen sich
fehlentscheidungen irrungen und
wirrungen malia valentin ein schnelltest
in der theorie ja in den schulen und
kitas vor ort nein und am arbeitsplatz
auch nicht jedenfalls nicht verbindlich
lockerungen jahr noch vor wenigen wochen
schutzvorkehrungen ein vom
kommunikations desaster über astra
zeneca einmal ganz abgesehen
das problem ist dass wir in dieser zeit
eigentlich mut entschlusskraft bräuchten
aber schlecht regiert werden verzagt
regiert werden dass wir gerade in eine
sackgasse geraten sind und das mitten am
beginn mitten in der dritten welle
dieser pandemie die so wahnsinnig
gefährlich für uns alle in diesem land
dienen die die konsequenzen sagen die
bürgerinnen und bürger die zeiten jeden
tag dass sie verantwortung übernehmen
können mit maske mit homeoffice mit
homeschooling ja all die die in der
pandemie arbeiten von der pflegekraft
bis zur verkäuferin den leuten die
ehrenamtlich arbeiten sie haben sie alle
erwähnt wenn wir aus fehlern lernen
wollen dann müssen wir die nächsten
schritte öffentlich beraten hier sie
müssen gut begründet sein und nicht
hinter verschlossenen türen hin und
hergeschoben hier in bundestag und
bundesrat bund und länder zusammen ja
selbstverständlich ja was denn sonst
meine damen und herren
haben wir haben wir als parlament schon
bewiesen dass das geht vor einem jahr in
diesem bundestag über parteigrenzen
hinweg haben wir gezeigt dass das geht
wir waren sehr schnell und wir haben
sogar in dieser zeit noch fehler
korrigieren können und jetzt die zahlen
steigen rasant
die menschen leiden gerade an der
pandemie genauso wie an der politik der
bundesregierung ich sage ihnen hierzu
wir sind als bündnis 90/die grünen
bereit gemeinsame vorausschauende
pragmatische pandemie bekämpfung auf der
mitte dieses haus zu machen
von mir aus noch diese woche wir können
das hier tun und wir können den
wellenbrecher die notbremse für diese
dritte welle ziehen wenn wir es wollen
wenn wir gemeinsam anpacken meine damen
ist ein riesen kraftakt konnte
natürlich ist ein riesenspieler ohne
schutzvorkehrungen zu öffnen
vor 14 tagen und deswegen brauchen wir
jetzt konsequente maßnahmen daran geht
es nicht vorbei es braucht ein plus von
vorsicht und vernunft eine echte
notbremse für die sicherheit der kinder
und lehrerin test kapazitäten die
tatsächlich in schulen und kitas da sind
es hilft nichts die verantwortung hin
und her zu schieben
man kann das ausrechnen wir brauchen 100
millionen tests 100 millionen wenn wir
alle kinder in diesem land zweimal die
woche testen wollen das ist nicht so
schwer auszurechnen und deswegen braucht
da nicht die abfrage bei den ländern
sondern einfach ausrechnen dann sagen
und die stehen auch bereit und jetzt
müssen sie verteilt werden damit sie an
die schulen und kitas kommen was eltern
100 grad ergebnis das gegenteil meine
damen und herren und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die büros wirklich zu sind
sie sind es immer noch nicht und dort
finden weiterhin in großraumbüros kann
die mäht reifen statt
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
betriebe runtergefahren werden natürlich
wieso redet eigentlich darüber keine und
keiner was in den unternehmen zum teil
gerade passiert wo eben immer noch keine
tests da sind und deswegen wäre es so
wichtig sie verbindlich zu machen
und natürlich muss klar sein dass die
urlaubs rückkehrerinnen verbindlich
getestet werden und dann bitte hier im
haus endlich einen verbindlichen
stufenplan festlegen einen verbindlichen
stufenplan ja klar macht in beide
richtungen
wann können wir öffnen unter welchen
bedingungen man muss wieder geschlossen
werden es kann doch nicht so schwer sein
meine damen und herren dass wir das hier
miteinander beschließen als klaren
rahmen der dann da bin ich bei ihnen der
dann regional ausgestaltet werden muss
natürlich aber daneben verbindlich
regional ausgestaltet werden muss und
nicht so dass notbremsen die klaren
zahlen orientiert sind irgendwie
interpretationsbedürftig das ist die das
ist für mich die entscheidende frage wir
müssen endlich vor die lage kommen
ich bin es auch leid das ist 1000
erklärungen gibt warum etwas nicht
funktioniert ich möchte endlich dass wir
hier 1000 lösungen diskutieren wie es
doch klappen kann
so wie beim impfen
so will man impfen eigentlich ein
meisterwerk der wissenschaft das hätte
auch durch ein meisterwerk der exekutive
ergänzt werden müssen natürlich war es
richtig dass europäische zu organisieren
keine frage es ist nicht gut gemacht
worden sagen jetzt alle muss man
korrigieren
bitte denken sie daran dass es dabei
bleibt dass diese krise auch nur global
bekämpft werden kann und dass der
impfstoff auch im globalen süden
ankommen muss meine damen und herren
ohne da werden wir ist nämlich auch
geschafft und ziehen wir den fokus bitte
weiter lernen wir nicht nur aus den
aktuellen fehlern lernen wir insgesamt
aus dieser krise jetzt ist die zeit für
eine bessere zukunft zu planen für
europa und für deutschland wenn wir
krisen und herausforderungen als etwas
betrachten was wir wirklich gemeinsam
lösen können mit mut statt mit wut herr
brehm haus dann schaffen wir ein neues
danach eines mit offenen restaurants und
offenen grenzen mit innenstädten voller
leben und für alle die besten orte
müssen die sein wo der zusammenhalt in
dieser gesellschaft gelebt wird wo wir
wissenschaft schätzen über die natur
leben
das ist die hoffnung die uns eigentlich
tragen kann
die hoffnung auf dieses wirklich danach
meine damen und herren alles ist drin in
diesem land es ist jetzt die zeit das
beste draus zu machen
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]